et maintenant tout de suite des
nouvelles de mireille darc j'apprenais
comme vous l'accident dont elle était
victime à l'heure du journal les
premières informations étaient même
alarmante en fait mireille darc a bien
supporté l'opération malgrè son coeur
fragile et ce soir elle se remet
lentement de ses blessures et nous irons
nous arrive de l'hôpital régionale
d'aoste sur l'état de santé de mireille
darc eux sont plutôt rassurantes
le dernier bulletin de santé nous dit
par exemple qu'il n'y a aucune fracture
du bassin
alors qu'on craignait le pire mireille
darc est tout à fait consciente elle
souffre de fractures multiples mais il
n'y aurait pas de problème particulier
en ce qui concerne son coeur elle
guérira c'est une question de temps
alain delon est arrivé hier soir à
l'hôpital d'aoste et bâle restant encore
ici jusque demain ou après-demain
ensuite l'emmènerait
sûrement dans un hôpital à genève où
elle restera à mon avis avant de sortir
au moins un mois
deux chambres parce que le temps que les
vertèbres sur soude
elle a au moins un mois de l'icco rct
après qu il n'y eu aucun problème avec
son que assistaient les problèmes
principaux des problèmes duc
problème je peux pas l'expliquer il
expliqué médicalement au techniquement
mais disons que
le problème majeur est un problème de
coagulation sans ces images de la
voiture détruite de mireille darc que
nous donne une idée assez précise de la
gravité de l'accident qui s'est produit
dans un tunnel à 140 ou 150 km/heure
donc mireille darc devrait quitter
l'hôpital d'aoste dans les prochains
jours pour la suisse et puis il y aura
un mois d'hospitalisation sans doute à
genève dans une actualité qui n'est pas
souvent bien guennou de sion parfois
d'extraire quelques messages d'espoir ou
simplement d'optimisme